Okay, now let's put this methodology to
work. Specifically, we're going to look at how to
synthesize a TCP IP protocol stack using
this methodology. Starting point of course is the
IO otometer. We specify the protocol in
all the detail that we want, abstractly. That's
the abstract specification of the protocol. And
we can prove that this abstract specification meets
the properties that we want in the protocol, using
the IOA framework. And from the abstract specification, through
a whole bunch of refinements, we can get to
the concrete specification. We saw that already. Those are
the two steps that we already mentioned how we
take and synthesize in complex software. The next part,
how do we synthesize the stack from the concrete
spec? In other words how do we generate this code,
the O comma code. That represents this abstract specification for the TCP/IP
protocol stack. So we need to have a starting point for that. The starting point
to get an unoptimized Ocaml implementation starting
from this concrete spec, is to use
this on symbol suite of microprotocols. That
the authors of this ensemble paper that
I've assigned to you have synthesized at Cornell. Why use
ensemble? Well, remember, our goal is to mimic the
methodology that is used in building real site, large-scale,
realized circuits. I mentioned at the outset that today,
building a billion transistor CPU chip, the way it works is they
use a component-based design, taking components of hardware
structures that have already been implemented And assemble them
together in order to realize this big, mammoth
chip. And we are trying to do the same
thing for building complex software systems. So the
starting point has got to be a set of
components, and that's what Ensemble Suite of microprotocols
give you. Now, if you think about a protocol
like TCP IP, that protocol has a lot of features in it, and each of those
features require nontrivial amount of code building. So, for instance TCP IP has
mechanisms for sliding window management... Flow control,
congestion control, scattering and gathering packets in
order to assemble messages into units that
can be delivered to the application. All of
these things are features of the TCP/IP
protocol. And the ensemble suite of microprotocols
has components for each of those functionalities.
That you might have in any complex transport
protocol, like TCPIP. And if you recall the paper that we read earlier by Tacket
and Levey about optimizing RPC in a local area network, we said that one size
fits all is not a good way to
think about designing complex software systems. Depending on what
the environment is, you have to adapt what the
layers of systems off it do. And therefore, even
though the TCP/IP protocol is well laid out in
terms of what the functional requirements are, whether we
need all of the components in a particular implementation
of TCP/IP or not is something that is up
for the designer to decide. And having
a suite of micro protocols, gives you that
freedom to mix and match the components that
make sense in this specific environment for which
to building a protocol stack. And that's the
reason for using the ensemble suite of micro
protocols. It has about 60 protocols that makeup
the whole ensemble suite. The suite of micro
protocols of ensemble written in Ocaml and
[UNKNOWN] component based design of a complex
system such as TCPIP protocol stack. And
the micro protocols have well defined interfaces that
allows composition. Every micro protocol has an
interface for the layers that sit on
top of it. An interface for interacting with layers that sit below it. And this
is exactly the kind of component that you want
so that you can actually assemble these components layer
by layer in order to get the functionality that
you want for the original protocol stack that you
intended to build. Just to reiterate what we said
in the, as the, just to reiterate what we
set as the original goal, we want to mimic
VLSI design in building a complex software system. And this
well defined interfaces of the on
symbol, microprotocol suite facilitates component based design.